I'm suicidal
you know
I'll put the rabbit
music
movers tapes as well poison that's what
my voice is like it is so Patricia tell
me where you from that's Angeles and
Shelley and what's your story you have
kids you have a husband you use divorce
I have eight kids he didn't marry three
times then proposed by the time I was
twenty-one seven times
Derek decided let me gain weight so
nobody will [ __ ] bother me do you
work
there's nobody it's time we met love you
it's that winning personality or fun
you're gone you know it's like when you
go to work me like oh my god it's you
know good work that person is there I
wasn't trying to be that one but life
just gave me it all I turned my frown
upside down
cuz I've been raped
I've been molested by my brother when I
was 24 came out of prison we came out of
prison I think we're drinking
I wanted to the bathroom and he threw
when I came out bathroom through in my
mom's bedroom and talked me
and the only thing I could say was oh my
god could my brother I couldn't look at
herself but then I thought [ __ ] me
I wasn't a prostitute but what I was was
I was family
financial
Advisor
to rectify
the household see you got a got a play
into that because that's what I had to
do like a [ __ ] a [ __ ] would
pick me up and I already had it in my
head oh you know what you forget a wife
at home do you be like jacking off
winner
that was like beat you no no no and I
could handle I know Oh unless in like
three months I was being like applause
do like you know might put it because I
had so much hate for the men that were
picking me
so I decided
I'll be against you
because if I'm your gangster I got
respect
electrica choose
this place is tight my eight kids want
it in ten years and that was just three
days ago just what I tell everybody put
your pinkie in my [ __ ]
because everybody knows that I brat I
make it just
because ass is a [ __ ] virgin
that's what God I will [ __ ] you up if
you touch that I'd only have one thing
yeah but anyway my mother's from New
York my father's from New York
so every time well I thought I had a bad
childhood because I was raising my kids
but reflecting up I pop easy
but I'm still a gangster normy I'm still
alive
are you drugs are using no I'm Vicki
you're drinking have you been up all
night yes
when you placement give me three
absolute black masses like you know this
you want me to suck [ __ ] no not today
all right everybody want to eat my [ __ ]
you know like why I understand that
because number one I'm gay
[ __ ] you're not getting my [ __ ]
can't even eat it right
I've been with this [ __ ] for 14 years
she can't even need a wooden hat [ __ ]
like she's like my wife has damaged
Patricia thank you so much for talking
to me you're very interesting in your
class you're a great guy whose apartment
I go to New York in three months do you
want to go to New York and things like
October no you're something else I
really enjoy you come today mother on